[Music]
I started out with thinking okay I'm
going to do something in the electric
vehicle space and that's why I
originally came to Stanford was to uh
work on uh Advanced Energy storage uh
Technologies in particular uh Ultra
capacitors um so that was continuing on
Research that i' done as an intern in
silen Valley in summer prior um so so
that's that's why I originally came out
in ' 95 and then during that summer I
wrote some internet software and I
thought okay I can either work on
electric vehicle technology or or I
could sort of work on internet stuff um
try try to do something with the
internet and I thought the internet
would be something that would
dramatically affect the future of
humanity it be like uh like acquiring a
nervous system um and whereas previously
communication would have to occur almost
by osmosis you know from one person to
another slowly through telephone or mail
or something like that but now um if you
have a nervous system any part of the
sort of human Collective know can know
about any other part instantly um and uh
you previously you'd have to be at the
sort of Library of Congress even to have
the Library of Congress is sort of
information um but with everything
digitized and access anywhere you could
be in a jungle in South America and and
if you had just an internet link somehow
you could You' have access to all of
Humanity's information so it would
actually effectively create a super
organism um and and fundamentally change
the nature of humanity
[Music]
itself